LOGAN URY: Thank
you all for coming.
This is the first in our series
about modern relationships,
and it's great to
have you all here.
My name is Logan Ury.
I help lead a team at Google
called the Irrational Lab.
We're a behavioral
economics team.
And we're very lucky to
have Sherry Turkle here
today in a conversation
about conversations.
Sherry is a MIT professor
who has spent the last 30
years studying the psychology
of people's relationships
with technology.
She's also the founder and
director of the MIT Initiative
on Technology and Self.
She's a licensed
psychologist and has
written four books
on our relationship
with digital culture.
These include "The Second
Self," "Life on the Screen,"
"Alone Together," and now
"Reclaiming Conversation."
Thank you for joining us.
SHERRY TURKLE: I'm delighted
to be here-- really delighted
LOGAN URY: So today we'll
be covering your new book,
"Reclaiming Conversation,"
how we can improve
romantic relationships,
how this relates to Google,
and then we'll open
it up to questions.
SHERRY TURKLE: Wait a minute.
Wait.
LOGAN URY: Yeah?
SHERRY TURKLE: How we can
improve romantic relationships
and how that relates to Google?
LOGAN URY: There's
a comma in between.
SHERRY TURKLE: There's a comma.
LOGAN URY: But it could
also be connected.
SHERRY TURKLE: I feel like
I really prepared for this,
and then all of a sudden
I felt unprepared.
I'd really gotten
myself together,
and then all of a sudden
I felt unprepared.
LOGAN URY: And for
those of you who
want to take out
that comma, we're
going to open it up for
the questions at the end.
SHERRY TURKLE: You have some
expertise I don't have, right.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
So just to start
off with the book,
you talk about how
reclaiming conversation
begins with reclaiming
our capacity for solitude.
SHERRY TURKLE: Yes.
LOGAN URY: Can you
talk about what
we lose when we're alone
because of our devices,
and what the value
of solitude is,
and how it's different
from loneliness?
SHERRY TURKLE: Right.
Well, I think that this
probably-- the professor in me
wants to say that this
probably is the most
important piece of my argument.
And here's why.
Criticisms of my work, even as
recently as a Pew study that
came out just a few months
ago, people say things like,
OK, well, look.
Let's give Sherry Turkle this.
If you're together with
your friends and you
take out a phone, not good.
Let's give her that, that
that kind of interrupts
the conversation and cuts
certain kinds of conversations
short.
But if you're alone and
you take out your phone,
why does that bother her?
What's it to her if,
when you're alone,
you're on the constant feed
and you can't-- what is she,
the Darth Vader of the internet?
I mean, what's with that?
And actually I do
make the argument
that solitude and the
capacity for conversation
and relationship go together,
and they go together like this.
Solitude is the capacity
to be alone with yourself,
to know who you are so that
when you come to another person,
you can hear what
they have to say
and not-- you can listen to them
and hear what they have to say
and who they are, and
not need to project who
you need them to be on to them.
And we all know that
when we meet somebody
who doesn't know who they
are, and who can't stand
to be alone, and comes
to us for, quote,
"conversation," they're not
having a conversation at all.
They're kind of glomming onto
us to get us to almost support
their fragile selves.
So if you, when you're
alone, are constantly
going to your phone
instead of being
able to tolerate that moment
of gathering yourself,
that's a kind of wake-up
call for you to make sure
that you're comfortable with
who you are and have cultivated
this capacity for solitude.
And recent research
is not happy research.
I mean, part of why
I wrote this book is
that recent research on solitude
and conversation is chilling.
There's this study that
shows that if you just
ask college students to
sit in a chair without--
and this is not my research,
but I'm reporting research.
You ask them to sit in
a chair without a phone,
without a book, and
say, we're going
to ask you to do this
for 6 to 15 minutes.
Are you good with that?
They say, sure.
Then you say, well,
we're going to ask you
to do this for 6 to 15 minutes.
Do you think that you'd want to
give yourself an electroshock
during that time?
They say, uh, I don't think so!
And they look as though
the researcher is crazy.
And then after six
minutes, they begin
to self-administer electroshocks
rather than just sit quietly
with their own thoughts.
And this actually is
borne out in my research.
I do research at
stop signs, where
that's like a three-second,
four-second stop.
People pull out a
phone at a stop sign.
They will not sit at a stop
sign without pulling out a phone
to check what's happening.
So perhaps enough said.
But there is a question.
Of course, in
"Reclaiming Conversation"
I go on and on about
how people talk
about their incapacity, their
anxiety about being alone
with their thoughts, and how
they want to fill that space up
with what's on their phone,
and what that anxiety
is about, and so forth.
So I actually think that
reclaiming conversation,
reclaiming relationship, does
begin with reclaiming ourselves
in solitude.
And this kind of false
dichotomy between,
oh, give it to Sherry
that we're together, OK,
we should lighten up with the
phone, but when we're alone,
it's none of her
business, I think
I'd like to break that down.
LOGAN URY: Great.
On a related note, the book
emphasizes the importance
of boredom, especially
for children.
SHERRY TURKLE: Yes.
LOGAN URY: Can you talk a bit
about what comes out of boredom
and why it's so important?
SHERRY TURKLE: Well,
neurophysiologically, a lot's
going on in boredom that is not
boring for your brain at all.
Boredom is the time when your
brain is actually establishing
what's called the default
mode network, which
is the brain's sense of its
stable, autobiographical self.
So in those moments of downtime,
your brain is very busy indeed.
And again, if your idea
of a moment of boredom
is an opportunity to fill in
with the feed on your phone,
you're depriving your brain
of something it really needs.
Beyond that, boredom
is considered
by most psychologists
to be one of the signal
achievements of childhood.
The capacity to be bored
and let your mind wander
is your imagination
calling to you to go inward
rather than to turn outward to
a phone or some other device.
Which is why somebody like
me is so concerned with baby
bouncers that have
slots for an iPad,
with potty trainers that
have slots for an iPad.
These things were either moments
where a caretaker and a child
should have been allowed to
engage in the beginnings of eye
contact, communication,
conversation,
or they're moments for reverie.
And to think that these are
minutes for screen stimulation
again is robbing us of
an important moment.
LOGAN URY: Another key theme
in the book is empathy.
And you mention
that a meta study
found a 40% decrease in
empathy in college students
over the past 20 years.
You also mention
that kids who spend
five days at a device-free camp
displayed much more empathy
than a control group.
What can you tell us
about the relationship
between technology and empathy?
SHERRY TURKLE: Well,
I would say that this
is the sort of
leitmotif of the book,
is this kind of empathy
crisis, because I was brought
in to studying the book
when I was asked to consult
by middle schools
about what teachers
felt were disturbing patterns
in middle school students.
Which I wouldn't have
known from my own life
as an MIT professor.
What I knew from my
life as an MIT professor
is that students didn't want
to come to office hours.
Students want to
send in an email
and compose a perfect
question, and have
me write them back
a perfect answer,
a kind of transactional model of
what goes on with a professor.
And I didn't have
reason to think it was
because they lacked empathy.
What I knew is that
they didn't know
the work that
conversation can do
in terms of sparking learning.
Because nobody who loves
learning or who grew up to be
a professor was because
they wrote a professor
a perfect letter and got
a perfect letter back.
It was because, on
the contrary, they
didn't have a perfect letter.
They came in with
nothing, or little,
and somebody said, well,
that's not very good,
but I'm going to stick with
you because I care about you.
Come back, and
we'll work on this.
It wasn't because
they wrote a perfect
and got a perfect return.
So I noticed a kind of lack,
a kind of transactional idea
about what a conversation was.
But then I was asked to
do this consulting work
in middle schools,
where teachers
were observing a lack of
empathy among younger kids.
And we're used to thinking
of cyberbullying as well.
People don't see the face.
And so, OK, they
cyberbullied because the face
isn't called up,
which is what calls up
the sort of moral
response in us.
Philosophers have
been telling us
that for years, that
it's the face that
calls up our moral selves.
But now psychology
is teaching us
that it's actually the lack of
a face, the lack of an identity,
is what causes this
online-- I call it
a sort of disinhibition
that leads to cyberbullying.
But now you're seeing that among
kids in face-to-face behavior.
The way one teacher put
it, that 12-year-olds play
on the playground
like 8-year-olds,
that they'll exclude a child,
and then they can't imagine,
they can't put themselves
in the place of that child.
They're not able to do
what empathy requires,
which is to put themselves
in the place of.
And the teachers began to
talk about that in one school.
And in their mind, it had to do
with the way these kids weren't
talking to each other, but
were really almost all the time
talking to each other
through their phones.
So in the lunchroom, their
way of talking to each other
was to take out their phones
and show each other what
was on their phones.
And in fact, when I went to
camps, these device-free camps
where the empathy
level goes way back up,
I think because kids
talk to each other
and get this practice in putting
yourself in the other person's
place-- I don't think this is
complicated-- the kids said
that what was different between
their relationships at camp
and at home was that
they spoke to each other,
not about what's on
their phones but what
was just happening at camp.
So there were signs from a lot
of different places and spaces
that there was something
up with empathy.
And since the early days
of working on this book,
this empathy gap has
certainly become a major theme
both in my work and
throughout the research
literature in psychology.
I will say that I recently just
spent a day with the woman who
did the study showing the 40%
decline in the past 20 years
among college students,
big empathy drop.
And she is developing
empathy apps for the iPhone.
And I think that's where
I'd love, in a Q&A,
to hear your thoughts.
I mean, because here
we are at a place where
it's not out of line to think
of you developing empathy apps.
And clearly I think of
us as the empathy app.
We are the empathy app, since
the way we develop empathy
is to talk to each other.
But I'm not closed
at all to the idea
of using technology to help
us in reclaiming empathy.
But my first instinct is,
we are the empathy app.
We need to talk to each other.
We need to talk to
our kids, that somehow
putting a baby in a baby bouncer
and putting a screen that
has an empathy app
in front of this baby
instead of putting
you-- and yet I
felt for her that
she was so upset
when she got this response.
She got this result. She
wanted to do something.
And I think that that's part of
one of the themes of the book,
is that it's not
anti-technology.
It's pro-conversation,
that sometimes we
just need to know when to
be there for each other.
So anyway, that's
my empathy story.
Clearly I'm-- oh, and also,
what's the difference between
empathy and compassion?
Since the book
came out-- I mean,
really I wrote it to
spark a conversation
about conversation.
There's been a lot
of talk about, well,
empathy isn't as
important as compassion.
I mean, look at all the
stuff we learned about places
all over the world because
we have the internet.
Now maybe the
important thing we have
is compassion for all these
things we don't know about,
and maybe empathy is
a little old-school.
So I'm here to say I don't
think empathy is old-school.
LOGAN URY: So now I
want to transition
a bit into talking about--
SHERRY TURKLE: Romance.
LOGAN URY: Modern romance.
So in the book, you
mention that the sight
of a phone on a table,
even if it's silent,
even if it turns over, worsens
the quality of the conversation
and makes it less empathetic.
SHERRY TURKLE: Yes.
LOGAN URY: So I'm definitely
going to take that advice.
I was wondering what other
advice you have for people here
who feel like
technology is getting
in the way of their
romantic connections.
SHERRY TURKLE: Well,
this study is amazing.
I mean, if you just did one
thing, but not just in romance,
in your families,
in your friendships,
with your children,
with your everybody--
so just make sure you understand
the setup of this experiment.
Take two people out to lunch.
Obviously you don't tell them
what the experiment is about.
You feed them their lunch.
On the table, there's a phone
turned off and turned over.
And you're measuring
their conversation
against a control
group with no phone.
Just the silent
phone on the table
will cause the conversation to
go to truly trivial matters.
And the people will report
less of a sense of connection
with each other, less of a
sense of caring about each other
or of understanding what's
on the other person's mind--
just the presence of that phone.
So they re-did the study.
I mean, it was such
an amazing study.
They re-did the study
in a natural setting.
Forget the laboratory and giving
people lunch in a laboratory.
In a natural setting
like a shopping mall,
and they just put the
phones on the periphery
of people's vision--
I mean, like
at the edge of people's vision.
And again they found that even
a silent phone disconnects us.
So the most important
thing you can do on a date,
or on a breakfast,
or at a lunch,
or at a business meeting, or at
an anything where your goal is
to have the conversation
not degrade to trivialities,
to maybe make an empathic
connection, like maybe
like a second date
where somebody-- or more
than that, the first
step in falling in love
has to be that somebody
feels that something big is
at stake-- is put
away your phone.
It's not enough to
turn off your phone.
Put away your phone.
Because a phone reminds
us, whether or not
we want it to
remind us, that you
have the capacity
to be elsewhere.
It's not even that you
want to be elsewhere,
but that you have the
capacity to be elsewhere.
So I think that before I go
on to other Turkle tips--
because I must say that
the research on this book--
and a whole chapter
is on romance--
I'm surprisingly filled
with tips and advice.
And the book was reviewed by
Jonathan Franzen in the "New
York Times," and he
described it as in part
a kind of like
totally high-class
academic self-help book.
And I couldn't figure out if
that was like good or bad.
LOGAN URY: I wanted
to ask you about that.
SHERRY TURKLE: On
the one hand, I
thought, kiss of death
with my colleagues,
like people will never
again invite me to lunch.
And then I thought, well, after
investigating conversation
and empathy, why
shouldn't I have
written a book that actually
tells some people things
about how to be an
advocate for conversation?
So I decided to own it.
So I'm OK with that.
But that is the most
important thing you can do,
is really sacred spaces.
Put away your phone.
And then sacred spaces
for conversation--
the dinner, the kitchen,
the dining room, the car.
The car.
You're driving-- and I
was about to cross myself,
even though I'm Jewish.
Really, it's not the place.
No devices.
And if you're in a family,
you tell your family,
we need to talk to each
other in this family.
That's important to
me in our family,
that we talk to each other.
That's just how
it's going to be.
It's easier to tell this to
somebody who's a younger child,
but an older child or a
boyfriend or girlfriend
you can also tell.
If you're sitting next to your
boyfriend-- you're driving--
and he takes out his phone,
you say, it's important to me
that we talk.
And if he doesn't like
it, you just repeat.
And then the same thing
if your girlfriend
is using that as her time to
catch up on her social media
feeds.
Create a culture
in the car where
that's a time for talking.
And I think that's
very important.
A third tip, and
this is something
that was so important in the
interviews I did on romance,
was the-- I call it
the nothing gambit.
In romance, so often what you
get back in texting is nothing.
And people talk to me about it.
They ask me, in
history, could you
ever do that before, people
just dropping out like nothing?
And, like, nothing?
And actually, people
could not call you back,
but that's a little different.
That's like a statement.
That's saying, I'm
not calling you back.
But it's not like in the middle
of a conversation-- I say this.
You say this.
I say this.
[SILENCE]
And people actually experience
that quite differently,
as, the date ends.
There's just nothing after.
And people sort of say, well,
she didn't call me back.
He didn't call me back.
You could check.
Some people check in to-- they
know they shouldn't, but they
do.
But sometimes
there's a check-in,
but people kind of know that
if there's a great quieting,
they know what happened.
But it's almost as though the
human nervous system isn't
set up for conversation in which
you say this, and I say this,
and I say this, and-- and
people find it quite upsetting.
And I would say that
it isn't a good way
to end your relationships
because it actually
causes distress and
disorientation, much
more than you mean to cause.
Because usually when people
are doing the nothing response,
all they're doing
is they're deciding
they really don't want
to go out anymore.
It's really like
not calling back.
But they're not
treating it like they're
in the middle of a conversation.
They're treating it
like they've had a date,
and they don't want to call her
again to go on another date,
or call him again.
But psychologically,
it's not like that.
LOGAN URY: So what
should people do instead?
SHERRY TURKLE: Well, the
best thing to do is say--
and this is the thing
that no one wants to do,
but again, it's to
have a conversation,
like I loved our date.
It was so fun, and I just loved
going to the [? Gotzengould ?]
opera.
It was amazing that you
thought to invite me there.
We share so little.
[LAUGHTER]
But in business, there's
this ridiculous--
when you have a
manuscript turned down,
or I don't know how many of you
have submitted film scripts,
there's this new
line, we've decided
to go in another direction.
Have you heard this?
Have you heard this
line, we've decided
to go in another direction?
It's actually a very
interesting line
because it basically doesn't
say your thing is bad.
It says, we've decided to
go in another direction.
You just say, you know,
I really had a good time,
but I think this just
isn't right for me.
And it's the functional
equivalent of,
I decided to go in
another direction.
Which the first
time I heard it, I
thought, oh, this
is so pretentious.
It must have been
invented in California.
But actually I've
come to appreciate it.
I've just come to appreciate
it because I think it actually
is very honest.
I mean, it actually is kind.
It's saying, I'm going--
it's accurate in some sort
of bizarre-- it's like, I'm
going in another direction.
So the kindest thing is
to just actually complete
the conversation.
I'm going in another direction.
Which is what you say
when you say that I think
that this isn't right for me.
I like "it isn't right for me."
Continuing on a romantic
basis isn't right for me.
So that's my love tip.
LOGAN URY: We'll
check on your mic.
On a related note, one of
the most memorable stories
in your book, and Aziz Ansari
also put this in his book
from your research,
was the story
of a young man
who had a standing
date with his grandparents
to have dinner there.
And when he wanted
to cancel, he just
wanted to send them a text or an
email to say he couldn't come.
And his mom said no.
SHERRY TURKLE: So did Aziz
quote me, or did I quote Aziz?
LOGAN URY: Aziz
quoted you, right?
SHERRY TURKLE: Yeah.
LOGAN URY: Yeah, OK.
SHERRY TURKLE: Because Aziz and
I worked together for a minute.
It could have been either.
LOGAN URY: I think
it's your research.
SHERRY TURKLE: Yeah.
LOGAN URY: So the mom said, you
have to call your grandparents.
And in calling the grandparents,
he heard the disappointment
in their voice.
They had already
started cooking.
They had set the table.
And it was much
harder to cancel.
And I just thought that
was so profound because
of not only how people break
up, but just general flakiness.
So maybe you can talk
a bit about that.
But I thought that was
just such a good tip, which
is if you want to
cancel plans, you
should suffer the
consequences of knowing
how it affects the person.
SHERRY TURKLE: Well, this has
also to do with apologizing.
What was nice about
this story was
that it came upon very
naturally in the family.
So this was the
mother's parents--
and they lived very close--
would invite the son over
to-- I think he was 11-- would
invite him over to dinner.
And it wasn't like Thanksgiving.
This wasn't Rosh Hashanah.
I mean, it was just like,
come over to dinner.
And as he got a
little bit older,
because it wasn't like a
big holiday or something,
he just got preoccupied
with other things.
And this thing settled in
where because he didn't
have to see them, he could
just type, I'm sorry,
can't come, and hit Send.
And it really was not
good for the family.
And he was not feeling that
he was causing distress.
And the mother just decided that
he had to at least call them
because when he
called, he got to hear,
your grandfather went to get
sundaes with caramel sauce,
and he got all the toppings,
like you do a sundae bar.
There's a roast in the oven.
I'm making your favorite
russet potatoes.
I mean, he got to hear
that actually they
were going to have this dinner
anyway, the grandfather liked
the caramel sauce
anyway, that it wasn't as
though these people were
incompetent and dependent
and were going to fall apart.
But he was going to be missed.
And I think that that's
what you don't get with,
I'm sorry, and hit Send.
Because the dance of what
happens in an apology--
I mean, take it to the higher
level for romantic purposes.
An apology is so important.
And in my book, I
interview a woman
who says, if my boyfriend
apologizes by phone,
I know 100% of the
time that we are
going to go back
over this again,
because none of the work
of an apology gets done.
Because in an apology, I get to
see-- I'm apologizing to you.
I get to see that you're upset.
Then you get to
see that I'm upset.
And so you soften.
You think, OK, she's really--
my grandmother used to say,
don't apologize until
you're contrite enough,
or it's not going to work.
Hold off.
Think about it
until you mean it,
or else it's not going to work.
An apology is not
saying I'm sorry.
You have to have this
whole dance go on.
So then you see I'm really
upset, and you soften.
What, you can't
make eye contact?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I didn't
do anything wrong.
SHERRY TURKLE: No, no, no, look.
But you see how hard it is?
Because then you have to
see that I really feel bad.
It's hard, because then you
have to see I really feel bad.
And then I see, ah,
I have an opening.
Now you can break
our eye contact.
I have an opening that I can
make something happen here.
But unless I see
that he-- the reason
I was disoriented
when he looked away
is because I was actually
trying to put myself
into that state of mind.
Do I have an opening with this
guy where if I say I'm sorry,
we can move to something else?
And that's a whole
complicated dance
of people learning empathy.
And if you don't do that,
if you don't teach that,
if you don't model that, if
you don't learn all of that,
you're missing a lot.
In a romantic context, that's
sort of back to basics.
I mean, people are hurting
each other all the time.
I mean, there's no way to have
a close relationship in which
you're not having bumps.
If you're not
having bumps, you're
not in a close relationship.
I mean, it's almost
you put it that way,
that it's not just like
in a close relationship,
there are obviously
going to be bumps.
But if there aren't
bumps, you're
not in a close relationship.
So being able to
have ways of saying,
hey, what I did
wasn't cool, or hey,
I can understand
how you felt there,
that becomes part of the
dance of the relationship.
And if you're not doing
that face to face,
the balance of things
isn't going to work.
So I would not use
texting for that purpose.
LOGAN URY: So that's
a great transition
into my next question,
which is about eye contact.
And I thought a lot about this
as I was reading your book,
and now as I'm talking to you.
And it just seems
like eye contact
is such a key part of exchanging
information and a developing
connection.
And a few months
ago, this article
came out about 36 questions
that lead to love.
And it ends with people
staring into each other's eyes
for four minutes.
So I think as we're going
through Turkle tips,
we should think a little
bit more about eye contact
and really what it
can do for intimacy.
SHERRY TURKLE: Right.
Well, obviously eye
contact is so important.
And that's why
really I want people
to think so hard about
screens in front of kids
during moments when parents
used to look at them.
I have a very close colleague
at MIT, Cynthia Breazeal,
who's developing robots
that will read to children.
And I certainly get the gist.
They will learn more
words, socioeconomic groups
that don't have words.
But really, money for people
who would be with those kids
and read to them-- I mean,
a half-million dollars
to have some people
reading to those kids
so they could make eye contact.
I really worry about that,
that they would actually
develop something that people
will put in their homes
so they can do their
email, and the robot
will read to the children.
I really worry about
this, or the idea
of putting a baby bouncer
and having an activity,
this slot for a pad.
Because eye contact is so
crucial for developmentally,
and it's so crucial
in every relationship.
And Skyping is so
interesting because in order
for-- let's say I'm
Skyping with you.
No, actually him.
LOGAN URY: You're next.
SHERRY TURKLE: In order-- no,
now you have to look at me.
[LAUGHTER]
In order to-- or
I'll Skype with him.
He wants to.
In order to Skype-- OK,
you don't want to Skype.
In order to Skype
with you, and for you
to have the feeling that
I'm looking at you, which
is crucial to me, let's say,
if I want you to bond with me,
if I want you to feel the
full blast of my attention,
I have to look at the camera.
So I can't be
looking at anything
happening in order to give you
the experience of I'm looking
at you.
Now, how effed up is that,
that I'm having no experience,
or I'm only pretending to
have an experience in order
to give you a fake experience
that I'm looking at you?
So Skyping is really
perfect for a couple.
Bringing you to the romantic
thing, you're in love.
You're at a distance.
You're in Chicago.
She's in New York.
You're cooking dinner.
You set up to Skype.
And as you're each cooking
dinner, you're on Skype,
and you're chatting.
And you have that
sense of co-presence,
and you're seeing each other's
bodies as you both cook dinner.
Fantastic.
In different states
of undress or whatever
you want, whatever
you want to do.
But that's what
it's optimized for.
It is not the place to do this.
And I've found, studying
different kinds of conference
calling where theoretically the
camera situation is much more
diffuse, so you should be able
to have that feeling of looking
in each other's eyes,
is also very complicated
because there comes a point
where somebody feels they're
in the main room
and some other group
feels they're not
in the main room.
And it usually
happens-- sometimes it's
not clear where the main
room is going to be.
There's like a little
bit of a power struggle,
like who's in the main room?
And then something happens,
some subtle shift, and some room
becomes the main room and some
room becomes not the main room.
And then the people who are
not in the main room, who
decide that they're not in
the main room, start to text.
And sometimes they start
to text under the table,
which is called phubbing.
And my students
tell me they know
how to do this, that they all
learned it in middle school
when they wanted to text, and
not be seen by their teachers.
So sometimes you see people
doing it under the table,
and then sometimes, as though
they aren't being seen,
they'll just be doing it right
there because they're not
in the main room.
So again, it has its place.
You're a global company.
You have to do it.
But it's more
like, have respect.
My message is, have
respect for this thing
that we know how to do
humanly, and it definitely
has its place.
And do it when you can,
and respect its power
when you get a chance to do it.
And in romance, I tell
a story of a couple who
choose-- this is this Adam and
Tessa couple who actually like
screen stuff
because, particularly
on the part of the guy, he
feels that he can be a better
self when he is online.
More empathic.
He can edit himself.
He can get it right.
I'm not going to ask for a
show of hands, but all of us
have had the feeling that--
I sometimes get angry.
You wouldn't believe that, but
I sometimes can get very angry.
And I have that
bitch-- that kind of
like just angry response.
And then online, I'm just, oh,
that's a kind of funny thing
to have had happen.
I'm a better person.
I can just have that
moment, and then I
don't have to show
it because I've
had that delay time to edit.
So we've all had that experience
of feeling like the better me
gets to be the one online.
So the guy in the
relationship, Adam,
really likes that, feels
that he is the better himself
in the online presentation.
And he's with a woman, Tessa,
who basically is telling him
that he's not empathic enough
throughout the relationship.
I mean, she ultimately
breaks up with him
because she's telling him
he's not empathic enough.
I mean, even online, even with
all these efforts after three
years, he hasn't reached
her empathy standard.
So love tip-- you are the self.
You can edit online
and be-- it's
good to be a more-- when you're
with people you care about,
and with people who
are working for you,
when with your loved ones,
nothing wrong about being
online and not having
that immediate bitch
response that I sometimes get.
You know, I'm overworked
and overstressed and running
around, and somebody
does something
which is going to
cost me three hours.
And I'm like, are
you kidding me?
That kind of response.
Nothing wrong with that, with
going online and suppressing
it.
But really let the people
you love see who you are.
Because it is the unedited
you that you have to accept,
that they have to accept,
that you have to work on,
and you have to feel loved for.
And it works in romance,
but more dangerously.
Parents-- again,
in the book, I talk
about parents wanting their
children to talk to robots.
And Hello Barbie or Siri--
Hello Barbie is a fancy one,
but all kinds of
sociable robots are
being invented to
talk to children,
to be their best friend,
to be their buddy.
And I talk about, from
a psychological point
of view, that danger lurks.
Because one of the
messages the child--
I mean, apart from
the fact that I
think pretend empathy
is toxic, but that's
such a different lecture that
I won't even get into it here.
In the book, I go into
this in great detail.
But apart from that,
you have to let
a child feel that their truth is
something that a parent can not
only tolerate but love.
And similarly, in romance,
at the end of the day,
you have to feel that
the truth of who you are
is what the person
you love can love.
So that is a more
profound-- since we
began on sort of putting
away your phone on a date,
this moves us to the deepest
level of tips for romance,
is you have to feel that the
person you're with actually
loves you, with all the
flaws, and loves who you are.
And there's something about
this going online and editing
yourself that can
interfere with that.
LOGAN URY: Thank you.
So I want to make sure
people in the audience
have time for questions, so
I'm going to let you choose
the next question from me.
First choice is, people
in the audience--
SHERRY TURKLE: Wait, I get
to choose the question?
LOGAN URY: I'm going to give
you my next two questions.
You choose which one to answer.
How does that feel?
The first one is,
we're at Google.
A lot of people in this
room probably make devices.
If you could design
any device that
would help reclaim conversation,
what would that be?
Your second choice is, if
you could take over-- I
like to ask this to everyone--
the google.com homepage for one
day so billions of
people around the world
would see something
under the Google logo,
what would you say?
SHERRY TURKLE: They
could click on my book.
[LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: Your publishers
love that answer.
SHERRY TURKLE: No, I want
people to read my book.
I do.
I mean, I really worked to--
this is a very different book
from other books I've written.
It is a lot of research.
I mean, for six years I've done
nothing but interview people.
I mean, it's not out of my head.
But I had a mission.
At the end of "Alone Together,"
all these people were saying,
I'd rather text than talk.
And I thought, I'm
a psychologist.
If they really mean it, there
are profound implications
for how kids are growing up, how
loving partners are relating,
how business is being done,
what families look like, what
solitude is looking like.
I want to do a kind of
ethnography of conversation
in America.
And if they mean it,
I want to tell them
that conversation is the
talking cure for the failing
connections of our digital life.
And they meant it.
There was this flight from
conversation that I really
hadn't-- "Alone Together"
really wasn't in a position
to document that.
It was about 1,000 other things.
So I was on a mission, which
was very different than "Alone
Together," where I'd done 15
years of NSF-funded research,
and I reported out.
Or the same thing for "The
Second Self" and "Life
on the Screen."
Whereas here, I kind
of wanted to know,
what was the state of
conversation in America today?
And if so, I felt very
strongly about conversation,
based on my life as a
psychologist and my training.
And I don't see why technology
can't be pro-conversation.
In other words, I think this is
absolutely a false dichotomy.
I don't think technology has
to take a stand against-- you
don't need to be anti-technology
to be pro-conversation.
I'm pro-technology,
pro-conversation.
So the idea that you're taking
a stand against technology
to be pro-conversation I think
is just very bad for technology
to be put in a position
where it's taking
a stand against conversation.
That has to end, because
that is not sustainable.
So this is just the last thing
I would say before questions,
that really I think the
future for a company
like this is to get on the
conversation bandwagon.
Because you want to find a way
to have conversation be part
of your message, conversation
be part of your product,
technology be easily
integrated into conversation.
Just like you don't want
computer-assisted learning
to be an anti-conversation
strategy.
You don't want
computer-assisted learning
to be something that closes
down conversation in schools.
And if you find
applications of computers
in schools that are closing down
conversations in classrooms,
you want to change
those applications.
I mean, I think that both
the money and the-- it's
not just the money.
But let's say the money.
I mean, the money-- I'll
take it on any level.
I mean, it's the
money, the humanism,
the forwardness, the future,
is for the corporate world
to enhance conversation, enhance
learning, enhance excitement.
You don't want
students who don't
want to come talk
to their professors
because they think
that they'll get
the right-- this
transactional model is not
where you want to go.
Yeah, so I wouldn't
mind everybody
at Google reading my book.
I think that that would be good.
LOGAN URY: That's great.
OK, well let's open it up.
Let's be pro-conversation--
SHERRY TURKLE: Pro-conversation.
LOGAN URY: --and open
it up to the audience.
OK, so just stand up, and
Scott will bring you the mic.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
It's on.
AUDIENCE: Is it on?
Great.
I thought I might start,
if you don't mind.
[LAUGHTER]
Do you have any thoughts
about online dating
and what happens
when relationships
are conceived online?
And so all of the initial
courtship occurs digitally,
and then they finally meet.
And I don't know
what happens there.
SHERRY TURKLE: Well, I've had
some hysterical interviews
with people who meet online,
and both partners don't
want to end the online part.
So finally one will say,
well, how long can this go on?
Because the online part is
so fulfilling because you're
very busy.
You're very-- either it's
going to get fantastic,
or it's going to end.
Everybody feels that
way about dating.
And online, you can be
the person you want to be.
They're being the
person they want to be.
And they're being the person who
they think you want them to be.
You're both being the
person you think--
we've all become very
good at picking up
online signals of who we
should be for other people.
I mean, that's another
skill set that's
being developed that
who knew we had,
of being able to
be-- I mean, that's
a new kind of empathy
that's useful,
but sort of gets
us into trouble.
Online, you know how to pick
up this new kind of empathy
that I don't even want to
call empathy because you're
playing to a fantasy thing.
It's not the old
kind of empathy.
It's not doing the work of
the old-fashioned empathy.
So I interviewed so many
people who could not get
that real person into the room.
I would say that you want to get
the real person into the room.
The idea that the longer
you keep it online,
the better it's going
to be because-- I would
say the longer it's
kept online, the greater
the chance that the
person who shows up
is going to be nothing like
the rare and totally perfect
creature that you've been
talking with for 18 months.
[LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: Good Turkle tip.
SHERRY TURKLE: Another
Turkle tip, right.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for coming.
I am really glad I came,
and I'm looking forward
to reading the
book, in large part
because I was a big fan of
your books from the first two,
actually.
In 1995, I remember
reading "Second Self"
and immediately
feeling like this idea
that people have identities
online that give them freedom--
SHERRY TURKLE: You mean
"Life on the Screen."
AUDIENCE: "Life on the
Screen," that's right.
That was the one
even earlier, then.
I read it in
probably 1994 or '95.
SHERRY TURKLE:
Right, early adopter.
AUDIENCE: I completely
wanted-- that book
made complete sense to me.
I was very receptive to it.
This book I'm
incredibly resistant to.
So that's a great sign
that I'm going to like it.
It's like I--
SHERRY TURKLE: Well, I'm
not-- I mean, you see me.
I'm not like a--
this is what I think.
I mean, this book,
AUDIENCE: Right.
And this is my question.
The two things that
leap to my mind
are largely historical when
I think about my resistance
to these.
We've had some of this before.
This doesn't at least
seem to me to be that new.
You have to kind of
go back in time a bit.
So a lot of what
you've talked about--
SHERRY TURKLE: Like the book?
AUDIENCE: The book
and letters were
the two things that struck me.
So I'm really curious
if you had a chance
to look at kind of
historically how
the rise of the cheap
paperback, for example,
and the experience of letters
challenged conversation
in their historical periods.
SHERRY TURKLE: Yes.
And I'm only sorry that
I didn't stop the book
and say, and now let me talk
about the book and letters,
because I should have.
But since I didn't, let me
just talk about it here.
So how many times have you
been talking to somebody--
if I went, you know what?
We're in this conversation,
but what I really want to do
is read, like, three
paragraphs of "Madame Bovary."
LOGAN URY: Never happened to me.
SHERRY TURKLE: So hold on.
I'll just get right back to you.
And you go to "Madame Bovary."
You read your paragraphs,
maybe just one paragraph.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I will
say kids do that.
Kids will do that.
SHERRY TURKLE: Right.
But you read a little "Madame
Bovary," and then you just say,
I'm back.
So it's what Linda Stone called
continual partial attention,
is that it's the
lack of segregation.
Because I think the book thing
is very important, more so
than the television example,
because in this book,
I use television as
a good example of how
we can turn things around.
Television is an example
of people jumping around
and making all kinds of
fuss about a technology that
could be used socially if you
wanted it to be used socially.
And why everybody
assumed that you
were going to be using
this not socially
is just like part
of the zeitgeist,
that people saw it as
destroying the family.
But in my family, watching
television was a contact sport.
So we sat around, watching
television and arguing
about what was happening
on the television
and fighting about what the
people on the television
were doing.
Well, it brought the
family completely together.
I watch television
with my daughter.
I mean, we watch
television together.
Obviously she's
graduated college now,
so she actually has less time
to watch television with me.
But we watch "Game
of Thrones" together,
and it's like our closest--
when they killed off
that whole family, I was
like, no fuckin' way.
I jumped up.
It's a very social--
watching "Game of Thrones,"
that's another tip.
I don't know if it's
a tip for romance,
but it's definitely a tip.
It's definitely a
tip for families who
feel they want to get closer.
I'm very big on television,
games, card games.
The point is, it's a technology,
but it's a technology
of talking and socialization.
The point is that.
So television is a great example
of how it's not the technology,
it's the social context.
So the trouble with
this kind of-- this
is because you're
telling somebody
who literally is-- you're in
the middle of a conversation.
You're a tape recorder.
I'm putting you on pause.
I'm going to the
people in my phone.
Or I have a lot of
data on how people
use this thing called
this rule of three,
where they're sitting at dinner.
You're six, and three people
have to have their heads
up before you go
down to your phone.
And it's basically just
the same as in the--
which is how college students
behave in dining halls.
And the conversation
stays light,
and people don't feel
connected to each other.
So that's the social norms
around using the phone.
People don't, at dinner, say,
we're at dinner together,
and I'm going to just read
a few paragraphs of my book.
Now, that's because
we have social norms.
It's not because they couldn't.
It's because we've just
evolved social norms that say,
really, no.
Not.
Don't do that.
And we can do that
for our phones.
So that's kind of my message.
It's not the phone.
It's that, how did it
come to pass in the past--
so as I was watching
this, this thing
unfolded, this rule of three.
How did it come to
pass that it was really
fine to go to dinner with four
people, and have two of them
on their phone?
And that's like what going
out with my faculty colleagues
is like.
That is not unusual.
And you say, why
is the phone here?
And they'll say, an emergency.
And then you ask
them-- I mean, I'm
allowed to ask them
because it's like I'm
pretending it's research.
What emergency?
And the bar is very low.
The bar is very low.
And that's what this
book is arguing,
that these are social rules.
We've just invented them.
They're extremely new.
And we didn't invent
them for the book.
And let's un-invent
them for the phone.
And that this is work
we know how to do.
I love my favorite
example-- I mean,
this is taking too long
to answer a question,
but my favorite example
of turning something
around is nutrition, actually.
Because I was raised
by a mother who adored
me-- and I use this example
a lot-- in the '50s and '60s
who fed me white bread and soup.
The main two ingredients
were sugar and salt,
with a little bit of
ketchup in the soup,
I think, a little
tomato something.
And fruit that had
like this sugary syrup
thing, and vegetables in a tin.
And she loved me.
I mean, it wasn't money.
And if I had fed that to my
daughter who just has graduated
college, I would have
been an abusive parent,
or it would have been like
a "Mad Men" retrospective
thing I was doing.
And it would have been like I
was doing a retro, fun evening.
But it would have been, we
know that we can't do that.
And obviously there are still
people who eat like that,
and that's still what's
on a lot of shelves.
But basically-- I was
looking for a little bit
of junk food in your
cafeteria because it's
been real-- I started
this morning at 5:00 AM.
It's been a very long day.
I couldn't find anything.
I couldn't find the basics
of the junk food option.
So we know that
this is not good,
and we've changed our diets.
That's now how we eat anymore.
And that's not how
I fed my daughter.
And we've turned-- it
didn't happen immediately.
There was a tremendous
amount of opposition.
It wasn't like the entire
food industry said,
you know, you are so right.
We just so completely
fucked up when we
tried to sell you that stuff.
We are so sorry that we broke
up the local food markets
and put everything on this
national food market that
gave you no fresh food.
Our bad.
That isn't how it happened.
It was like a social movement.
It was a political movement.
It was very hard.
It's not done.
It's not even done.
But you know, it's
kind of getting done.
And I believe that's going
to happen with phones.
And education, and
that's why I think
that a company like this-- I
mean, just to say it again,
just in case you
didn't catch it,
you should be in the forefront
of making that happen.
Think of yourself just
being the forefront
of making that happen.
AUDIENCE: You
talked a little bit
about being pro-technology
and pro-conversation,
and I wanted to get
your thoughts on,
as a researcher,
what's important for us
when we're designing
technology to incorporate
in what we're doing.
Because sometimes we create
technology that kind of
wipes out part of the usual
human interaction instead
of augmenting or enforcing.
SHERRY TURKLE: Well,
keep this in mind.
I mean, when she said, what do I
really wish on the Google page,
I said, read the book.
Think about conversation
as a design criteria.
I mean, I think
Skype is fascinating.
I mean, I really want
to know why there can't
be a technical fix to this.
I want somebody to sit
down and explain to me
why there can't be,
after how many years
has this product been out?
There's got to be a
technical fix where
in order for my daughter to
feel that I'm giving her eye
contact, I have to be literally
not looking at her for an hour.
LOGAN URY: Does anyone here
work on the Hangouts team?
[LAUGHTER]
SHERRY TURKLE: I think that's
really an interesting-- I mean,
here's a really popular product.
And people use it to look
kind of like, uh-huh.
And to me, its very
basic thing that it's
supposed to accomplish, it's
taken itself out of the game.
So you should all
consult to them
and tell them how they
can upgrade themselves,
or somebody should.
Or there's got to be a technical
fix where you look at something
and it changes your game.
I mean, it's got to be
some physics or-- I mean,
it's got to be something.
Gotta get some hacker on that.
[LAUGHTER]
No, seriously, because
this is ridiculous.
In order to make
you feel that I'm
giving you my full attention--
because I'll tell you
what's important.
I'm trained as a psychoanalyst.
And now psychoanalysts are
doing psychoanalysis by Skype
to China.
And all these Chinese
psychoanalysts
are not-- to give them eye
contact for supervising
sessions, where you
can't be staring
like this in a
supervising session,
they're going to be
staring at a camera
and never looking at the
person they're supervising.
This is crazy because you have
to look at the person you're
supervising.
So this is so crazy.
This is like 15
articles' worth of crazy,
to be giving someone clinical
supervision without actually
looking at them.
Because technically
it's not possible to.
Don't get me started.
AUDIENCE: We're
missing out on empathy
as we see less empathy,
especially among kids.
Does that mean that
we're being replaced
by the opposite of empathy?
I'm thinking,
what's the opposite
of empathy, selfishness?
But then there's
also self-doubt.
And you mentioned when
you're eating lunch
with your colleagues, and
they pull out their phone,
why did you pull out your phone?
It's an emergency.
To me, that sounds
like self-doubt,
that maybe you're scared, and
you need to look at the phone
because my relationship
is in a place where
I need to be responsive
to this person,
or my relationship
will collapse.
And you have so
many relationships
where you're looking
at your phone
because you have
so much self-doubt,
so if you don't
respond, you're going
to endanger your relationship.
Or maybe it is just selfishness.
Every Facebook Like that you
get, every new Tinder match,
just boosts your
self-confidence.
SHERRY TURKLE: This
is so depressing.
This is like an interview,
with you describing
why people are-- yes!
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm curious.
SHERRY TURKLE: The answer
to this would be yes.
AUDIENCE: What are you seeing?
Are we--
SHERRY TURKLE: I'm
seeing all of this.
I'm seeing all of this.
I'm seeing people insecure
in their relationships.
If you don't talk
to people, you get
insecure in your relationship.
That's what I say.
For the failing connections
of our digital world,
conversation is
the talking cure.
Because if your relationship
is too much online,
you will get insecure
in that relationship.
It's going to happen.
AUDIENCE: So you
think that it's fear
that's driving people towards--
SHERRY TURKLE: I think you
get a lot of self-doubt if you
don't-- I mean, just having been
with you for just a very short
time, I feel confident
in our connection.
You just feel confident in
the connection with someone.
With you, I feel very confident.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, we're built for this.
This is what I mean.
I mean, we have to at
some point acknowledge
what we are built for.
We are built for eye contact,
conversation, bodies together.
We're built for this.
And we're putting
ourselves-- and it's better
to design for what
we're built for.
And then we want to
expand our horizons.
We want to expand the things we
can do, great with technology.
But we should design
around our vulnerability.
But I think you're right.
Where you're right
is that a lot of-- I
don't mean to say
that technology is
causing some of these problems.
I think technology
is enabling people
to not have face-to-face
conversations that they'd
just as soon avoid.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
about what metrics
for measuring empathy
you've encountered,
and what your
analysis of that is.
SHERRY TURKLE: Well, the
metrics for measuring empathy
are very simple.
There are tests, and there
are many, many tests,
where basically you tell a
story or you show a film.
And then you basically
say, what is this person--
can you put yourself in the
point of view of this person?
Can you put yourself in the
point of view of that person?
Now let's switch.
What is this person feeling?
And it's very primitive.
But it gives you a sense of
whether or not people are
able to do this perspectival
switching and being
able to put themselves in the
perspective of other people.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
So I have a question
that's not about phones,
but it's about empathy, since
you've done a lot of research
into empathy.
So what I'm curious
about is, can you
compare now versus in history--
people's empathetic behavior
in the second half
of the 20th century
and 21st century-- versus how
people behaved 200 years ago,
300 years ago, 400 years ago?
Do you think we're more
empathetic or less empathetic?
Or can you characterize
it at all in that way?
SHERRY TURKLE: Well,
it's very hard.
I mean, obviously
we're not doing
these-- I don't
want to say things
where I couldn't possibly give
a scientific answer because we
didn't do these tests.
So we can only measure--
AUDIENCE: I'm only
interested in your opinion.
I--
SHERRY TURKLE: Right.
What I think is that the
capacity for conversation
and the fact of conversation
generates empathic connection.
And I believe that we had
more conversation when we
didn't have other distractions.
And so I extrapolate
from that that we
became practiced at what
you get out of conversation,
which is reading other people.
That's really all I can say.
But my concern-- I
mean, just say this
again so that--
everybody hear me right.
My concern really is not in
proving that we're on a-- I'm
not Ray Kurzweil.
I'm not trying to
prove [INAUDIBLE]
that we're on a slope up or
a slope down or on a slope
to being robots.
I'm just saying,
in our moment now,
if you care about
empathy now-- so this
is why I want to
just sort of keep it
to what I'm an expert on.
In our moment now, if you
care about this value now,
we're not on a good trajectory,
and technology is an enabler.
Right now, the way we're
socially using the phones now,
technology is enabling us on
a path that's not helpful.
And we can turn it around,
because actually we
are the empathy app for the kind
of empathy I'm talking about.
That really is all my
research and my methodology
can bring to you, to be most
humble about what I can say.
So that's my message.
This kind of understanding,
it matters deeply to me.
I think that raising children,
raising human beings without
it, is not going to be-- we
freak out about Asperger's.
We freak out when people
don't make eye contact.
We freak out when they
don't connect with us.
And we're putting screens
in front of babies
at the very moments that
were the key moments when
we know that we're
supposed to be
making eye contact with them.
So my favorite
line in my book-- I
don't know if I said
it-- is that technology
makes us forget what
we know about life.
So my message, just
to close, is remember
what you know about life,
whether it's in dating,
where you really don't
want somebody looking
at their phone-- if somebody's
looking at their phone
during a date, I say, look.
They're not your person.
But if you say to them, look,
that's not the kind of thing--
I'd rather you didn't, and they
start giving you a hard time,
how this is important because
it might be an emergency,
they're not your person.
They're not your person.
I mean, they're not your person.
They should be trying to
make eye contact with you
and just figuring out how
they're going to do that.
So remember what
you know about life.
If you're fighting with
somebody about their phone,
and on a date, they're
not your person.
And remember what you know
about life with your kids,
that they need your eye contact.
They need your connection.
And start the conversation.
Thank you.
LOGAN URY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SHERRY TURKLE: Thank you.
LOGAN URY: It was
great talking to you.